اليوم السابع لوقوع هذه الكارثه هذا
الزلزال المدمر دخل قبل حوالي ساعتين اقل
حتى من ساعتين ساعه ونصف ما زالت اعمال
الانقاذ في بعض المواقع في غازي عنتاب
مستمره كما نشاهد في الخلفيه هنا في هذا
الموقع اعمال ازاله الانقاض والبحث عن
ناجين ما تزال مستمره بعض المواقع تم
الانتهاء منها ان كان في غازي عنتاب او في
ولايات اخرى لكن في مواقع
تحدث ذوي بعض العالقين بوجود اشخاص ما
زالوا تحت الانقاض تستمر عمليات الانقاذ
طبعا في محاوله اما للوصول لناجين وهذا ما
تعمل
تعمله فرق الانقاذ او في محاوله لانتشال
جثث العالقين تحت الانقاض طبعا
على الهواء مباشره
ماذا تفعل مجموعه الانقاذ
في محاوله التاكد فيما اذا كان هناك تحت
هذه الكتله اشخاص عالقين او هناك مسافه
معينه يمكن من خلالهم توجيه نداءات الى
اشخاص
اذا كانوا احياء في الداخل وبانتظار اي
استجابه لكن حتى الان هم يحاولون ويقومون
بفحص المكان في عده مناطق ويبدو ان في هذه
النقطه التي يعملون فيها الان يحاولون
احداث فجوى
لمحاوله ارسال نداء للعالقين تحت الانقاض